هذه مقبره مسيحيه تابعه للكنيسه الانجيليه
وتقع بالقرب من منطقه بابا الخليل في
القدس المحتله وتعتبر مقبره تاريخيه تضم
رفاه العديد من رجال الدين والعلماء
والعسكريين المسيحيين اقيمت منذ اكثر من
150 عاما مع بدايه هذا العام في خضم
الاعياد المسيحيه تعرضت هذه المقبره
الاعتداء من قبل مستوطنين قاموا بتكسير
شواهد قبور وصلبان في المقبره ورغم ان
كاميرات المراقبه رصدت اثنين من
المستوطنين وهم يقومون به تدمير شواهد
القبور الا انه ايه لا يتم محاسبه
المستوطنين وقد تعرضت هذه المقبره بالفعل
الاعتداءات عده في السابق كان اخرها عام
2014 عندما قام مست
بتدمير ما لا يقل عن 40 من شواهد قبور هذه
المقبره هذا الاعتداء هو واحد من اعتداءات
متكرره ضد المقدسات المسيحيه وبحسب مصادر
كنسيه تم تسجيل اكثر من 100 اعتداء خلال
السنوات الخمس الاخيره ضد كنائس واماكن
مقدسه ومقابر وكان هناك ايضا اعتداءات على
رجال دين لفظيا وجسديا هذا بالاضافه الى
الاستيلاء على عقارات واملاك تابعه لكنائس
اللجنه الرئاسيه العليا لشؤون الكنائس في
فلسطين ادانت الاعتداء واعتبرتهم انتهاكا
عنصريا اخر واستمرار لانتهاك اسرائيل
ومستوطنيها لحرمه المقدسات وقالت ان تحديد
الوجود المسيحي هو جزء من محاربه
الفلسطيني بشكل عام وتحديدا في مدينه
القدس
نجمان سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله